legally it's certainly conceivable that  states which  wanted to make the covet vaccine  mandatory could do it  then you would get into questions like  does it apply  to people who are legally residents of  the state what if you're traveling  through what if you're temporarily  working in a particular state there's a  ton of complexity  that's not really the issue for me i am  not  actively for mandatory vaccination  i'm for informing people and encouraging  vaccination in other ways  but it would be political suicide to try  to make the covet  vaccine mandatory many of the people who  don't want to get vaccinated  really don't want to get vaccinated and  i believe it would be unmitigated  political disaster for anyone who tries  to push mandatory vaccinations